et
trois avions de la patrouille de l'armée
de l'air italienne se percutent lors
d'un meeting aérien en allemagne
fédérale et s'écrase sur la foule
premier bilan une trentaine de morts et
une centaine de blessés le premier
ministre annonce pour le 6 novembre
référendum sur le statut de la nouvelle
calédonie au terme d'un séjour pendant
lequel il a voulu redonner espoir aux
deux communautés
inaugurée officiellement seulement
demain le pont de l'île de ré et déjà
ouvert depuis 100 jours fait un des
succès de l'essai 7 mille passages par
jour mais la polémique n'est pas éteinte
entre les partisans et les adversaires
de sa construction
madame monsieur bonsoir
alors que nous avons tous encore en
mémoire l'accident de l'airbus dans un
meeting aérien à mulhouse en juin
dernier qui avait fait trois victimes
une nouvelle tragédie a eu lieu cet
après-midi en allemagne fédérale près de
la ville de rammstein cette fois ce sont
trois avions de la patrouille de
démonstration de l'armée de l'air
italienne qui se sont percutés en vol
avant de s'écraser sur les spectateurs
qui se trouvaient en dessous
pour l'instant les sauveteurs en sont
encore à secourir les victimes sur place
sur le terrain et le premier bilan très
pop très provisoire que l'on peut
établir est d'une trentaine de morts et
d'une centaine de blessés
voici tout de suite le document qui nous
montre l'accident d'abord et les minutes
qui ont tout de suite après suivi le
drame
agnès poirier en plein ciel
une figure de voltige à basse altitude
comment réalise souvent la patrouille
italienne
et puis l'accident deux avions en faire
que la troisième un appareil explose
instantanément un autre s'écrase sur la
tribune officielle le troisième sabine
sur une piste secondaire envahi par les
spectateurs sur la base américaine de
ramstein les trois avions légers
ailleurs mcgee sandra la panique gagne
la recherche de proches
on attend le surcoût comme tous les ans
la journée portes ouvertes a attiré
beaucoup de monde on compte plus de
30000 spectateurs
quatre heures après le drame impossible
de dresser un bilan définitif 30 mans
peut être plus d'une centaine de blessés
dont ils sont atteints de graves
brûlures
les trois pilotes ont été tués sur le
coup le peuple allemand et ce soir en
état de choc après de nombreux accidents
provoqués par des avions militaires
les vols à basse attitude suscite là bas
une vive polémique et les instances
locales et régionales avaient même
demandé l'interdiction du meeting de
rammstein oui après ce drame un autre
accident a eu lieu aujourd'hui en
belgique un avion finlandais s'est
écrasé au sol au cours d'un meeting
aérien également le pilote a été tué
mais aucun spectateur n'a été
heureusement touché en france ce week
end est celui des grands retours de
vacances cinq millions d'automobilistes
sur les routes c'est un chiffre
approximatif mais qui n'est pas loin de
la vérité jusqu'à ce soir un trafic
heureusement est relativement fluide
il est encore bien sûr trop tôt pour
dresser un bilan des accidents et savoir
si les français ont été sensibles aux
chiffres 1087 collision en juillet et
puis également aux avertissements qui
leur ont été prodigués donné cette
semaine par le premier ministre en
personne
un constat un tenant donc qui n'a pas
valeur de statistiques ni de sondage
durant toute la matinée de ce dimanche
une de nos équipes à circuler sur une
route nationale et ensuite sur une
autoroute pour y traquer les mauvais
penchants de nos concitoyens au volant
valérie fournis roger moore
nous voulons actuellement l'autoroute
a10 à hauteur de chambre et au sud de
tours le ton ou ta kittel dont vous la
circulation est dense
chronique d'un jour de retour de
vacances
même aujourd'hui les acharnés de la
vitesse sévissent sur les routes
les gens dorment e veil et relève les
abus aux dix ans ou dix ans verte 157
kilomètres heure la vitesse est pourtant
limitée à 90 km heure sur cette
nationale et dès 9 heures ce matin la
gendarmerie de melun verbalise risque
une sanction sur deux plans d'abord une
sanction pénale qui peut être une amende
pécuniaire et d'autre part une
suspension de clamer de conduire une
sanction administrative de prononcée par
le préfet du département qui est
également une suspension de permis de
conduire
est ce qu'il sait dysphasie fpt a
certainement surtout la suspension de
permis de conduire plus apparemment que
l'amendé pécuniaire 1 que les gens
acceptent facilement mais enfin c'est ce
qu'ils craignent surtout la suspension
des microbes aucune excuse ne pourra
être donné le radar et fiable cette
femme roulait l 121 km heure par un de
moins pas un de plus une certaine façon
de faire réviser son compteur
mais le mal des français reste une
accumulation de mauvaises habitudes de
conduite sur l'autoroute
ils conduisent à gauche chassant les
voitures trop lente à l'heure où
l'espace de sécurité rarement respectées
regardez nous roulons à 130
kilomètres/heure vitesse limite sur
autoroute en une demi-heure ils seront
53 à nous doubler dans une moindre
mesure on pouvait craindre également des
retards et des bouchons dans le ciel de
france ce week end fin du mois d'août on
se souvient en effet des embouteillages
aérien du début de l'été et bien
visiblement les mesures qui ont été
prises depuis portent leurs fruits
le ciel est resté aujourd'hui
relativement limpide au dessus de nous
et les avions sont arrivés dans les
temps
maryse malo quand les parking d'aéroport
sont dans cet état
on peut craindre les pires retard
surtout le dernier week-end du mois
d'août
or depuis vendredi aucun avion n'est
rentré après le couvre ceux d'orly soit
23h30
il faut dire que cette année air inter
offre deux fois moins de vols
supplémentaires que l'an dernier pour
autant de vacanciers a rapatrié le fait
taire intérim moins de vols
supplémentaires reprend effectivement
une diminution de la charge des
contrôleurs en ce qui concerne le trafic
des rames ter bien sûr mais les
passagers n'ont pas été lésés pour ça
puisque grâce à l'utilisation de deux
gros porteurs
nous avons pu offrir la langue de sièges
plus important que celui des longs
offert les dernières pour la rentrée des
vacances
la compagnie joue les gros porteurs car
rien ne sert d'affréter trop d'avions
s'ils ne peuvent pas décoller première
décision sage
reste que les contrôleurs auront
surveiller 13600 vols depuis vendredi
sans encombre c'est là qu'intervient la
cellule de crise mise en place en mai
dernier cinq hommes cinq téléphones en
liaison avec les centres de contrôle
aérien son rôle
prévoir les retards potentiels pour agir
avant que le bouchon ne se forment une
des actions possibles c'est 2
demandez aux contrôleurs du centre
concernés de prendre en compte les
avions une altitude inférieure à celle
qu'ils utilisent habituellement pour les
faire voler dans une zone moins encombré
ce qui permet à ce moment là de les
faire partir beaucoup plus rapidement ce
qui est le cas de la région lyonnaise
vers la région parisienne et ce qui a pu
être fait plusieurs fois
en clair les avions volent dans tous les
couloirs aériens et il arrive que les
contrôleurs ferme momentanément le
robinet de l'espace aux vols
internationaux de transit pour l'offrir
aux avion des lignes intérieures
résultat si les passagers d'air inter
n'ont pas connu de retard important
ceux qui rentraient des baléares n'en
diront peut-être pas autant mais c'est à
ce prix que la rentrée s'effectue dans
l'ordre la politique le premier ministre
est en route pour paris de retour de
nouvelle calédonie avant son départ il a
annoncé qu'il proposait la date du 6
novembre pour le référendum les français
seront à cette date donc appelés à
ratifier ou non les accords signés entre
le fln ks et le rpcr sur le statut du
territoire en attendant
l'autodétermination dans dix ans tout au
long de ces trois jours de visite michel
rocard aura tenu à respecter un parfait
équilibre scrupuleux équilibre dans les
paroles d'espérance qu'il a prononcé en
direction des deux communautés caldoches
d'un côté kanak de l'autre rachid arhab
georges en scène le drapeau symbole de
la jeunesse et cette jeunesse
je vous demande que ce drapeau grandi à
l'ombre
m
michel rocard a accepté avec émotion le
drapeau kanak offert par un
indépendantiste de cannes à la chef du
fn 15 tout au long de ces trois jours de
visite le premier ministre a tenu à voir
tout le monde les indépendantistes les
loyalistes mais aussi les gendarmes
michel rocard aimerait cicatriser toutes
les plaies de ce territoire français du
bout du monde en trois jours le premier
ministre a également rencontré tous les
responsables politiques calédoniens à
qui il a annoncé aujourd'hui la date du
prochain référendum fixé au 6 novembre
un scrutin national dont le premier
ministre sait qu'il risque de ne pas
passionner les français
je m'attends un dos très forte
abstention
j'ai même risqué un chiffre je ne vois
pas pourquoi je ne les risquerais pas de
nouveau je pense que si nous dépassons
40% de participation ce sera déjà pas
mal et je voudrais que l'on comprenne
bien
nous sommes dans une situation où il est
probable je ne veux engager personne
enfin on peut espérer que les trois
principales forces politiques du pays
peut-être quatre vont donner leur accord
au statut proposé pour la nouvelle
calédonie par voie référendaire
voilà pourquoi il faut même pas faire du
taux de participation un enjeu on le
prendra comme il est nous espérons
servir la cause de la paix et du
développement de la nouvelle calédonie
du mieux possible et de cela je ne ferai
pas un enjeu le premier ministre qui a
glané dans l'opinion les fruits des
accords de matignon ne veut visiblement
pas se laisser embarquer dans une
bataille électorale qui juge inutile
michel rocard prend les devants en
demandant à l'opposition de ne pas faire
de l'avenir de la nouvelle calédonie un
thème de la rentrée politique en
métropole chez rocard vous l'avez
entendu n'espère pas plus de 40% de
votants pour ce référendum est bien le
premier sondage sur ce thème réalisé par
ipsos pour le compte du magazine le
point est plus optimiste que le premier
ministre 69 % des personnes interrogées
se déclarent prêtes à aller voter ce
jour-là le 6 novembre
l'accord signé sur la nouvelle calédonie
à paris vous le savez également fait
pratiquement l'unanimité de la classe
politique française etc
si on fait du front national jean marie
le pen qui faisait ce week-end sa
rentrée politique chez lui en bretagne à
la trinité sur mer est résolument contre
et privé à une exception près de
représentation au parlement
il adopte également des positions très
dures vis-à-vis de l'opposition de
droite
roland sicard patrick gabet jean marie
le pen termine ses vacances en famille
pratiquant l'art d'être grand-père ou
celui de cultiver son jardin le
président du front national a eu le
temps de réfléchir et la situation
politique a changé privé de groupes
parlementaires privé de tribune à
l'assemblée nationale le front national
doit maintenant haussé le ton pour faire
entendre sa voix résultat le discours
s'est durci première cible
l'udf et le rpr jean marie le pen tire
la leçon de son désistement au second
tour des élections législatives ne faut
pas que les politiciens rpr et udf pense
que de reconduire ont cette technique de
cadeaux aux élections locales
par conséquent là où il y aura alliance
il y aura soutien loyal du front
national là où il n'y aura pas alliance
les parties en question prendront la
responsabilité de leur échec
avertissements l udf et rpr mais jean
marie le pen concentre son tir sur le
gouvernement et les socialistes en mode
attaque la nouvelle calédonie le
président du front national accuse
michel rocard de haute trahison dans les
conduites de cette affaire annonce qu'il
votera non lors du référendum sur
l'avenir du territoire et dénonce par
avance la consultation sur
l'autodétermination prévu dans l'île
pour 1998
la première question qui doit se poser
quand ils s'agit d'un territoire
français ce n'est pas quel est l'intérêt
de la fleur ou quel est l'intérêt de
chiba au mais quel est l'intérêt de la
france
je dirais même que cette question là est
préalable à celle du souhaite exprime
les populations si respectable que
soient leurs opinions
en effet même si l'opinion se trouvait
en dés
corps nouvelle calédonie avec l'intérêt
de la france celui ci devrait s'imposer
jean-marie le pen annonce la couleur
entre son parti et les autres formations
politiques pas question de consensus
l'extrême droite de se faire entendre
elles marquent ces différences le front
national est d'ores et déjà en campagne
électorale
oui
un dernier mot de politique d'une
manière générale après à l'élection
présidentielle de juin 2 mai dernier et
l'accord sur la nouvelle calédonie les
français ont une bonne opinion du
président de la république et de son
premier ministre
selon un sondage ipsos pour le compte du
magazine le point
67% des personnes interrogées ont une
très bonne ou une bonne opinion de
monsieur mitterrand et c'est encore
meilleur pour monsieur michel roca 69%
de bonne ou de très bonnes opinions
étrangers et la pologne dû d'abord on
s'est peut-être réjouit un peu trop vite
en pensant que des négociations sans
conditions allaient s'ouvrir entre le
gouvernement d'un côté et les grévistes
de l'autre en fait à l'intérieur du
comité central du parti communiste
polonais actuellement réunis à varsovie
un débat très vif très dur s'est engagée
entre les partisans de l'ouverture et
ceux qui affirment que la situation
économique du pays ne permet pas
d'accorder des augmentations de salaire
en ce moment beaucoup de membres du
comité central du parti communiste
polonais se sont prononcés pour la
fermeté à l'égard des grèves et non aux
augmentations salariales
l'état ne peut pas se permettre le
premier ministre a proposé le gel des
prix et des salaires jusqu'à la fin
d'année afin d'enrayer la poussée de
l'inflation non également à
l'instauration du pluralisme syndical
dans les entreprises les travailleurs
ont quatre ou se regrouper au sein des
syndicats officiels
voilà qui ne va pas réjouir la classe
ouvrière quant à l'aise dans les airs le
président du syndicat interdit
solidarité il a réintégré les chantiers
navals de temps toujours envie de
toujours après l'appel lancé par le
pouvoir à une table ronde avec
l'opposition
le prix nobel de la paix n'a toujours
pas été invités à y participer
il ya donc préféré rejoindre ses
camarades carnaval sous haute
surveillance à londres dans la banlieue
de notting hill chaque année a lieu le
carnaval de toute la communauté noire
britanniques principalement immigrés et
des caraïbes la jamaïque
l'année dernière ces festivités avaient
dégénéré en violente bagarre faisant
plusieurs victimes
et bien ce dimanche et jusqu'à présent
tout s'est passé sans incident philippe
harrouard
c'est le plus grand rassemblement de rue
en europe plus d'un million de personnes
qui se retrouvent pendant deux jours
dans l'ouest de londres dans un espace
grand comme un mouchoir de poche
le carnaval de notting hill 23e édition
c'est aussi et surtout la grande fait de
la communauté noire de grande bretagne
et d'ailleurs c'est la seule façon pour
les noirs une fois par an de s'exprimer
de montrer ce qu'ils peuvent créer ou
faire lorsqu ils échappent aux
stéréotypes dans les têtes on les
enferme trop souvent des criminels des
bons à rien des chômeurs le temps me
diop a un peu perturbé la fête ce
dimanche pour la journée des enfants
on espère que demain pour le défilé du
carnaval ce sera mieux car en
confectionne chars et costumes
depuis avril dernier la musique est
omniprésente et est partie de la culture
de la tradition de chaque groupe ici
présents qui tient fièrement a rappelé
ses origines
cette année le festival 88 et placé sous
haute surveillance à cause des incidents
de l'an dernier où il ya eu un meurtre
et de nombreux blessés
l'an dernier on a recensé encore 812 250
blessés et une nuits d'émeutes cette
année le comité du carnaval a dû
difficilement négocier avec un peu lisse
certain nombre de règles à respecter il
y a dix mille policiers le tiers de la
force londonienne sur place la fête est
moins spontané que d'habitude mais c'est
pour le bien de tous car si le carnaval
tourner au vinaigre
encore une fois il pourrait bien être
supprimés le carnaval de notting hill a
été créée par les immigrés des caraïbes
arrivé il ya 30 ans dans ce quartier un
des rares de londres où les acceptait il
a été créé pour remettre du baume au
coeur des noirs victimes
il ya trente ans des neutres raciale ici
même trente ans après la méfiance reste
de mise entre noirs et blancs nés ce
carnaval de notting hill est considéré
par la communauté noire comme un geste
pacifique et de bonne volonté de sa part
rectification d'une erreur que j'ai
commise tout à l'heure en début de
journal à propos des accidents de la
route en france en juillet il fallait
comprendre 1087 tuer et non 1080 cet
accident
en france la polémique semble déjà loin
est dépassé il y à 100 jours maintenant
que le pont de l'île de ré est ouvert
même s'il ne sera officiellement
inaugurée que demain matin
un succès incontestable sept mille
passages par jour en juillet et en août
deux fois plus que lorsqu'il fallait
emprunter le bac mais partisans et
adversaires du pont ne sont pas pour
autant réconcilier rémy roche ils
étaient six seebach qui assurait 16
heures par jour la liaison avec l'île de
ré courte traversée 20 minutes mais en
saison jusqu'à 70 d'attentes avant de
pouvoir embarquer autre inconvénient les
bacs s'arrêtait la nuit quant à leur
exploitation l accuser un déficit annuel
de 17 millions de francs
outre 88 au plus fort de l'été
circulation parfaitement fluide au poste
de péage du nouveau pont pourtant les
passages ont augmenté de 90% par rapport
à la saison dernière
nous ne sommes plus prisonnier distance
orient ceux qui habitent ils toute
l'année et pour le président du conseil
général de charente maritime
ce pont est une victoire personnelle
face à ceux qui l'ont combattu au nom de
la défense de l'environnement je suis
aménageurs de profession et je suis
convaincu que la nature est spontanément
hostile et que c'est l'homme qui a qui a
vocation et qui a réussi dans cette
vocation
c'est l'homme qui a vocation à aménager
le monde pour son meilleur bien-être
alors je crois que ce pont fait partie
des aménagements qui assureront plus de
bien-être à ceux qui le dessert les
voitures par milliers des navettes
incessantes de bus on n'avait jamais vu
autant de monde sur l'île
les commerçants sont ravis mais prudent
en se demandant si une fois les
estivants reparti leur clientèle
habituelle ne préférera pas aller faire
son marché sur le continent
de leur côté les anti puntistes n'ont
pas désarmé il dénonce les aménagements
routiers qui ont été faits afin d'éviter
les embouteillages monstres de l'été
mais sur d'où ils redoutent l'arrivée en
force des pavillonneurs sur des zones
encore préservée aujourd'hui
actuellement le marché immobilier très
porteur sur l'île de ré et je doute
qu'on prenne des mesures dont qui sont
des mesures par un drastique sont
douloureuses pour les propriétaires
fonciers
je doute qu'on prenne ces mesures à
chaud qu'il fallait les prendre à froid
vous pensez que le pont est
véritablement responsable de cela non
absolument pas responsables de la
politique de l'île de ré a été donc mené
depuis 1968 70 en vue d'une organisation
massive mais le pont joue donc
l'effet l'accélérateur toutes les
mesures nécessaires ont déjà été prises
rétorquent les pouvoirs publics non
seulement afin d'éviter l'urbanisation
sauvage mais également pour préserver
les activités traditionnelles de l'île
et du même coup et maintenir une
véritable vie sociale toute l'année le
pont permettrait alors à lille de sauver
son identité fragile tout en s'ouvrant
au plus grand nombre paraît difficile on
ne tardera pas à savoir s'il pouvait
être tenu bien qu'il ne soit plus le
premier journal de france il reste l'un
des titres les plus connus
france-soir a quitté la nuit dernière
ses locaux historiques de la rue réaumur
à paris en plein coeur de la capitale
sur le site ça c'est pour les amateurs
de petites histoires sur le site présumé
de la cour des miracles pour la
déménagement pour la rue de bercy dans
le 12e arrondissement
un déménagement qui sera l'occasion
également d'une tentative de redémarrage
du quotidien qui a vu ses ventes
sérieusement chuté ces dernières années
trois cent mille exemplaires aujourd'hui
alors qu'après la guerre à l'époque
glorieuse de pierre lazareff
le tirage dépassaient le million
jean-marc brami christian hot france
soir des ménages sous l'oeil impassible
de pierre lazareff le quotidien
échappent ainsi à son lieu de naissance
la rue réaumur pour des locaux plus
modernes situé à un jet de pierre du
palais omnisports de bercy prélude un
lifting devenu indispensable
informatisation de la rédaction nouvelle
maquette en préparation passage à la
couleur
ce départ est tout un symbole pour
philippe bouvard directeur du journal
il ya des réformes qu'on ne peut pas
faire dans un cadre ancien l'immeuble de
la rue réaumur qui est un immeuble quasi
historique dans lequel nous trouvions
depuis
la libération n'était pas totalement
adapté à l'informatisation est un pas de
progrès techniques qui vont maintenant
devenir notre lot quotidien
le sens réaumur s'était révélé au fil du
temps mal adapté surtout trop vaste
douze mille mètres carrés de locaux pour
un journal qui a certes dans le passé
franchi le cap du million d'exemplaires
quotidiens mais tire actuellement à 400
milles fred baudin se souvient quand je
suis arrivé à france soir c'était en
font 45
je devais peser à peu près 45 kg car je
rentrais déportation et j'ai demandé à
voir le rédacteur en chef que j'ai
connue dans la presse clandestine
puisque je vais participer à la
confection défense de la france qui est
devenue françois j naturellement guy bon
nombre à la personne qui me recevait qui
n'était autre que robert salmon le
premier président de france soir
fond de teint et kimathi fred baudin
votre place est réservée par millions
j'en suis encore ému de vous chanter et
aujourd'hui pour la rédaction s'est déjà
penser à demain déménagement ou pas dès
lundi à 5 heures du matin france soir
sera comme d'habitude dans tous les
kiosques sport une arrivée mouvementée
aux championnats du monde cycliste
professionnel en belgique aujourd'hui
son championnat remporté pas l italien
fondriest au sprint en effet le canadien
bauer vous allez le voir à véritablement
balancer comme on dit dans le jargon
cycliste
le belge creek et lyon qui allait gagner
conséquence des classements de bauer et
un français à la deuxième place martial
gayant steve bauer et le belge clic et
lyon en tête d'un sprint à trois à 150
mètres de l'arrivée
pourtant sur le podium c'est le
troisième l'italien fondriest qui est
champion du monde
alors que s'est-il passé pour bien
comprendre suivait steve bauer au centre
le canadien en difficulté change de
rapports et provoque la chute de criques
et lyon
sur ce deuxième ralenti criquelion
essaye de passer à droite mais bauer le
poussent du coude et la roue de cliquer
lyon valeur t il bornes en béton
c'est la chute irréversible
une chute très spectaculaire du belge
qui laisse le champ libre à l'italien
maurizio fondriest qui remporte à 23 ans
son premier titre mondial
bauer d'éclat fait là sa deuxième place
au français martial gayant beau tir
groupé des français avec roland pensec à
la 6e place et laurent fignon qui
termine 8ème en belgique encore mais
cette fois ci automobiles grand prix de
formule 1 à spa-francorchamps premier
sénat deuxième prost vous avez compris
et bien le français a pratiquement perdu
toutes ses chances de remporter le
championnat du monde de la saison 87 88
pour battre son coéquipier brésilien il
lui faudrait en effet remporté quatre
des cinq derniers grands prix de l'année
lionel chamoulaud 11e grand prix de la
saison dans les ardennes belges sur le
circuit de spa francorchamps le plus
long de tous les circuits 6 km 940 à
parcourir 43 fois le plus long mais
aussi l'un des plus rapides et dès le
départ prost semble en mesure d'imposer
sa volonté il passe à ayrton senna au
premier virage
prost devant donc mais pour peu pour
très peu de temps car magic senna refait
la leçon aux professeurs sénat reprend
le contrôle des événements dès lors
alain prost ne peut plus revenir sur le
brésilien qui a su faire les bons
réglages
j'avais des réglages différents
il a mis les mêmes que moi donc j'ai
voulu moins de changer avant le départ
pour essayer de faire la différence et
j'ai roulé avec moins d'appuis
aérodynamiques pour essayer de de
consommer moi j'ai consommé beaucoup
moins cuit d'accord mais j'étais
beaucoup moins et derrière les deux
monstres de la formule 1 les
explications sont sévères entre capelli
et patrese par exemple
mais aussi entre mannini et nelson
piquet est ce la se tutoie l'italien
passe il terminera 4e derrière bout de
scène et alain prost et ayrton senna
vainqueur pour la cinquième fois cette
saison c'est ma reçoit l'hommage d'alain
prost au micro lionel chamoulaud donc
c'est très bien comme ça c'est tout à
fait logique donc très content pour lui
et c'est très bien aussi pour l'équipe
donc mais non mais s'il gagne et tout et
ayrton champion du monde
alain champagne également pour ceux qui
ont gagné le tiercé ou le quarté cet
après midi à deauville vous allez voir
les rapports s'inscrire sur votre écran
de quoi se payer un jéroboam de
champagne comme lé champion de formula
automobile 15 7 14 et vous ajoutez le 11
pour ce qui concerne le quarté avec 43,9
qu'on peut se payer quelques bouteilles
voilà ce journal est terminée les
dernières informations vous seront
présentés tout à l'heure aux alentours
de 23h par mon excellent confrère
philippe lefait tout de suite après le
journal il ya les prévisions météo avec
josé blanc lapierre premier rendez vous
avec nous demain matin 6h 45 télématin
et puis demain soir à 20 heures
vous retrouverez ici même henri sannier
je vous souhaite une excellente semaine
à samedi prochain bonsoir